the five nominated for Best Picture of
the year are American Graffiti a
universal Lucasfilm limited are limited
only a Coppola company production
Universal Francis Ford Coppola producer
I'm nervous that really upset me I think
I'm jealous Gary Kurtz co-producer cries
and whispers a Swedish Film Institute
cinema Matic graphic a B production new
world pictures in Barre Bergman producer
The Exorcist Hoyer productions Warner
Brothers William Peter Blatty producer
the sting the Universal Bill Phillips
George Roy hill film production zanuck
Brown presentation universal tourney
bill Michael Julia Phillips produces a
touch of class Brut productions avec Oh
embassy Melvin Frank producer the winner
is and I have the envelope
all right Sokka
the winner is the sting
well I would just like to say thank you
to the motion picture business and
industry and people whoever you are and
wherever you are that have have made my
12 years so much fun and given me so
many friends and it looks like there's
another year to follow thank you you can
imagine what a trip this is for a Jewish
girl from Great Neck tonight I get to
win an Academy Award and meet Elizabeth
Taylor all in the same moment thank you
so much my prepared remarks went out the
window also I just want to thank David
Ward for making this possible and George
Roy hill for making it happen and my
partner's Tony and Julia for bringing me
into this incredible industry
you